foreign
a lot of people were very skeptical
about
how would women how would we be with
these units how would we perform are we
going to be a liability
and a lot of those concerns aren't
unwarranted it's the unknown
um
but also on principle you never know
until you give people a chance to try so
that's
that's what our first group is there to
do we were the first ones not everyone
is going to be able to be a combat
Soldier
but everyone
is entitled to a chance the cultural
support team was a program started by
the
um
Army Special Operations program and it
was birthed out of many years of our
time in Afghanistan where you have
Special Operation Forces like Special
Forces Army Ranger Navy Seals who are
working in Afghanistan going after high
value targets from Al Qaeda and the
Taliban
so they go on these raids and they're
there to find these high value targets
and also gather critical intelligence
but one thing that they were missing was
being able to engage with the women and
children on Target because of the Afghan
culture
the American forces were not allowed to
talk to the women and children there was
this Niche need where that only women
could fill
when I first went to Afghanistan and was
embedded with the 75th Ranger regiment
for me
I I had uh some folks that understood
hey it has to be kind of lonely and
Uncharted being the only woman there
um and and some some Rangers that
befriended me which I appreciated
but initially a lot really kept their
distance it was about two weeks before
anyone really talked to me it was very
lonely it was uh not
not welcoming kind of a more cold
reception it was a lot of I think wait
and see and prove yourself
which
happens to even new Rangers so a lot of
it wasn't necessarily based on being a
woman but yes some of it was there was a
lot more I think scrutiny and skepticism
on how are we going to perform but it
wasn't an easy Road it definitely took a
while to change some hearts and Minds
within our own our own Special Operation
Forces
when I left
there was such an attitude shift when I
left these Rangers were saying you know
it's kind of weird that they don't even
let women go to go to Ranger school like
they let men who aren't in combat arms
go like why why can't women and when I
left one of the Rangers gave me their
their patch and said that'd be really
cool if you like
um
come a ranger one day
the reasons why Afghan women
were recruited to end up doing the
cultural support team job they were they
were dubbed the female tactical platoon
so that was the name for the Afghan
women we needed to build up the internal
Afghan capacity to be able to
govern and secure themselves
so this also included units that are
capable of doing these type of direct
action raids going after high value
targets
the roles were essentially the same
what is different though is
the level of Courage
that I think it takes to actually raise
your hand and do that job there's just
so much more risk for them agreeing to
associate and do this job do a job that
is Leaps and Bounds ahead of what Afghan
women are doing in society let alone the
military and let alone the highest
echelons of their military
they completely threaten what the
Taliban stands for and wants to
Institute under their governance
there absolutely was impact and there
was impact in
the advancement of women
the success of the cultural support team
program was huge in that
a lot of what we proved that we could do
there played a big role in the
Department of Defense ultimately
rescinding the women on combat ban now
the same goes for these Afghan women and
them proving themselves on the
battlefield right there with their male
Afghan counterparts culturally has huge
impacts on how women are viewed and
revered in society really I want these
stories to go to the next generation of
service women and hopefully they can be
inspired by it